well
you know
the thing
about this mess is and i i bring it up
all the time certainly when i'm talking
to dr drew who still lives in california
it's always anytime i talk to anyone
with a couple of brain cells rub
together it's like they always go well
we got to bottom out
and we haven't quite bottomed out yet
but we'll bottom out and then when we
bottom out then we'll we'll change
and i go
can't we see ourselves bottoming out
like why do we always have to completely
bottom out yeah you know what i mean
like like it's basically like saying
you know i got a 15 year old daughter
and i had to remove all the nail polish
remover from her room because she was
huffing it
and you go with you want to get her some
help i got to wait till she od's like
i'll wait till she flat lines
and here you go yeah how about getting
her some counseling now she's she's
drinking
nail polish remover like yeah but she
hasn't flat she hasn't gone into cardiac
arrest
it's like yeah oh
okay
so
california is bottoming out but we've
not
utterly bottomed out and so we have to
wait until we physically make contact
with the floor of the basement and then
we'll go
you know i think we got to get some new
new thoughts in here
i'm dave rubin and as you guys know i am
off the grid for august in an
undisclosed location but we went ahead
and pre-taped some incredible fabulous
wonderful groundbreaking interviews for
you in july and joining me today is the
host of the adam corolla show and the
author of many books i believe this is
his sixth but his newest book right here
in my hand everything reminds me of
something advice answers but no
apologies adam corolla welcome back to
the reuben report
always good to see you dave
corolla uh i have to
have a little maya culpa up top here i'm
off the grid right now and as i'm
interviewing you just a few days before
the end of july i have not read the book
yet because i'm going to read it in
august but is it fair to say this is
your best work ever
no
but it's up there
and you know you have to understand my
best work ever is pretty damn funny
this is pretty damn funny too i it's
it's really
hard to kind of rank them people like in
50 years will all be chicks you know and
they like not taco bell material but
you know i it's hard for me to do it but
if you go on
uh amazon it had a 4.8 it toggles
between like a 4.7 star and a 4.8 star
my other books are
four five four six you know so it's uh
yeah it arguably is ranked a little a
little higher review-wise
but uh it's it's up there everything's
above a 4.5
i think what you're really trying to say
is that your best work does involve a
trampoline is that what you're really
saying that's there and it's all in the
rearview mirror
speaking of the rear view mirror uh i
don't see you in person anymore because
i left california in the rear view
mirror you're still there you're on the
short list of sane people how's it going
over there you all right do you need any
money or help what can i do for you
it's uh not good you know um i know
people always kind of talk about the
grid and wildfires and you know
homelessness and and uh
drug trafficking and uh crime street
crime and everything but i i will sort
of paint you a a picture
of how la and california is doing
um we tried to open a bridge in la like
two weeks ago and it had to be closed
down
because too much
street racing too many
people climbing it and threatening to
jump off too much graffiti there we
literally attempted to open a bridge
in the middle of la
to the tune of 600 million dollars
and two weeks after it was open it's now
closed
because the people
could not
figure out a way to walk across it
without tagging it threatening to jump
off or or shifting somebody with a shank
that's so you're saying i made the right
decision is that what you're telling me
i think i i think so i mean you have
bridges in florida and they're mostly
open
seem fine to me
from what i can
get a gator under them every now and
again but they're functioning and uh you
just go to the other side
and it's humid they're talking okay
we're talking about putting speed bumps
in this bridge
and putting a medium in the middle of it
because people can't stop from doing
donuts in the middle of the bridge
i feel like the nonsense of la and
california must be particularly hard for
a guy like you because
when i think of you first you're very
functional you like things that work
you're a contractor you like things that
make sense
and yet you live in a place where
nothing makes sense have you thought
about that spiritually
yeah if you're wired the way i'm wired
and you're very mechanical and pragmatic
it does
make
no sense to you know
you
you turn on the tv in the
los angeles um commissioner's board or
the la council committee or whatever
is
seven insane women in their mid-60s
wearing masks on zoom calls
talking about you know re-masking the
kids before we open the schools and
comparing wearing a mask to wearing
shoes you don't think wearing shoes is
restrictive it's more restrictive than
wearing a mask like
just insane middle-aged cows setting
policy so yes it is it is a i for a guy
like me i would i would like somebody
with some experience in the private
sector
making normal decisions for the citizens
it's like it's like being in a city run
by the ladies of the view i really don't
know how you do it anymore honestly
that's right that's what you're up to
exactly that's exactly what it is this
is exactly what it is it's just an
insane um
cadre
of yentas who have feelings about
wearing masks and have you know it's
like rachelle wilinski head of the cdc
when she was up there like i'm speaking
as a mother i have a bad feeling like no
one gives a [ __ ] about your feelings
witch
just make some policy would you i don't
care that you look up all right i'll
tell you what i'm a dad
and i got a bad feeling that the schools
are going to be closed and that my son's
going to have to wear a mask for no
reason so are we even now
in the feelings department
i feel like you just gave ben shapiro a
great idea for his next book no one
gives a [ __ ] about your feelings witch
that feels like you could co-write that
with him i think
i'd love it
so uh i believe because i do do my
research although i said i i'm going to
read this thing in august i believe in
chapter four you say you're going to
stay till your kids are out of high
school and then you're going to get the
hell out is that is that really the plan
oh yeah you have to you can't
run a business or you know try to
function in la or california
any other way i mean i guess
you could work for the tsa
i imagine and stay in california but you
can't practically do it if you're trying
to
run a run a business so yes i would have
to leave
speaking of the craziness of the world
uh as we're recording this right now it
sounds like we're in a recession as of
this morning on july 28th we are in a
recession although uh they have thus
changed the definition of recession in
real time and edit it on wikipedia
things don't seem to be going very well
did they edit it on wikipedia there's
been 30 as of today there's been 37
edits on the official recession page on
wikipedia but you can see it all over on
cnn everybody's editing you know they're
just a recession isn't two consecutive
uh quarters of gdp going down now it
also there's other factors and and the
feelings thing and all that
yeah it's it's really interesting
i always think about kamala harris
talking to lester holt about the border
and he's like have you been to the
border and she's like oh uh well
yeah we've been to the border
you've been to the border we have and
then he goes
but have you been to the border and
she's like
i haven't been to europe what are we
talking about
the most interesting thing about that
exchange is not her sort of lying
it's her at the end she goes
i i don't know what you're asking like
you don't know what i'm asking you
you're you're the borders are
let's just say you're the queen of the
mardi gras parade
and i said have you been to mardi gras
would you be confused and go i don't
know what you i don't know what you're
asking or that's the craziest part about
the sort of new world order which is
like this weird semantic overload thing
where we just get bogged down and what
what is a recession what's a border i
don't know it's all invisible we can't
define what's a woman i i can't yeah
exactly so it's not definable so how are
we gonna i mean it's like it's like you
go in like when you're in the sixth
grade and you're like you you go in and
teachers like did you bring your
homework and you went
what's homework
uh it's the assignment that was assigned
to you when you left on friday i don't
know what that yes there i have seen
homework if that's what you're asking
like it's just weird circle talk
and it's by the way uh you dodged a
bullet because you're gay but uh when
you argue with women that's how you
argue you start to talk about things
you don't even know what you're talking
about anymore
and and that's kind of the new world
order what what is a recession i don't
know here's how i define it
are you surprised
are you surprised that all of this is so
idiotic that everyone involved with all
of this at every level seems like a
complete [ __ ] or incomplete dereliction
of their duty or an idiot or an
incompetent or a psychopath i mean you
feel it you feel free to use some other
adjectives like just the whole thing
there's just nobody
well look as i've said many times
if you can argue the definition but of
what is a woman or the difference
between a man and woman if if that's
open to debate
then
going to the border or recession is
certainly on the table
you know what i mean like if you really
think about
the ultimate black and white definition
man woman okay that's out the window so
a recession that's easy to argue away if
you can argue away a woman you know what
i mean and i sort of think a lot of
that's the motivation for a lot of it
because
they will argue away anything now
because everything is on on the table
now the the question you're sort of
asking is is
well you know joe biden kamala harris
whomever
i get it that's their job
but
i mean it's insane but that's what
they're doing
the question is more like
what are the news outlets doing
what are they aren't they worried about
their credibility don't they sound
insane
i i mean
i get it you're a cheerleader for a
party
but at what
you know you're essentially saying i'm a
cheerleader in a football game and the
other team just scored and you go no
they didn't
it's like yes they did no well what is
your definition of a touchdown then it's
like
cnn you sound insane
and people stop listening and why are
you making this deal with the devil why
are you cashing in every bit of goodwill
you've earned over the last 50 years on
stupid things just give it up
you know this this
this or or going like all in on january
6. you know it's the worst you know at a
democracy hanging by a thread the worst
attack since pearl harbor like your news
outlet or ivermectins for horses
you know why are you why are you
giving it up
why are you playing so fast and loose
with your dignity
your news outlet
you don't listen anymore do you think
it's too late and we should just
encourage they're slow or i guess at
this point they're relatively quick
death it's been a slow death that i
think is now escalating
um i don't know like my feeling is is uh
if somebody popped onto msnbc and said
look um
we traditionally
define a recession as two quarters of
negative growth and that's what we got
so that's what we're in i'd go all right
well at least that guy's
sounds semi-shane
right but there aren't too many of those
guys over there but you know i've asked
you this before but i don't think we've
done anything on camera since since you
brought me back from off the grid last
september so about 11 months ago uh
you're a hollywood guy you've you've had
a lot of success in hollywood you still
live in la when you think about all of
these the people that you're talking
about that are just sort of in on all of
the lies i mean an awful lot of the
hollywood people they're just they're
just kind of in the lie do you get
invited to any parties anymore when's
the last time you've been out of the
house
um well i'm out now technically
but not to your own building
since since you left i don't get invited
to too many parties
is it really like that like
uh there's an element yes there's a
strong element of not getting invited to
things you used to get invited to for
sure yeah uh not
not with certain friends or older
friends or guys have known for a long
time or you know that sort of stuff but
yeah sure there's there's an element of
that
that's what they do they're you know
first off they're cowards secondly
there's something
they're into mccarthyism big time which
is weird because they never shut up
about mccarthyism but they love to
practice mccarthyism every chance they
get and then they
complain more about mccarthyism
um
so yeah that's that's what hollywood
does
tell me about the book here because when
i saw the uh the cover here and i saw
the title everything reminds me of
something
but this is corolla because that's you
right like when you when you're doing
your show everything that you hear
you're interviewing somebody you're
doing the news everything reminds you of
something that happened way back when
that is the adam corolla
yeah it's something i came out of my
mouth like five years ago and i went
yeah that's true everything does remind
me of something and i thought it'd be a
good title
for a book
and
the book is people asking questions
versus me sitting down
and posing my own questions
which is kind of what you do when you
write a book you go well here's what i
want to talk about and here's and it's
it's an interesting conceit because it's
like
a authoring a book is sort of asking
yourself a question like what should we
do about the homeless problem here's
what we need to do about the homeless
problem you know but this is a little
different
and that people were asking me questions
and i had to form thoughts and opinions
on questions that i wasn't asking myself
so i found myself going hmm
yeah why is that
and then i was kind of pushed outside of
my box and had to figure out what is the
answer to that question because they
were not my own
yeah what's like the most burning thing
that you were asked that you really
maybe hadn't thought through you you're
a thinker
you're doing a daily podcast man you
talk to people on the internet
uh the one that pops into my head
and there were many but the the one i i
remember and you also
people have to remember or consider
i write these books i write them
while i'm doing 10 other things
and then they come out and then people
go what's your favorite chapter whatever
it is i can't remember anything i i was
there i did it and now i'm gone and i
don't know
um but
uh somebody said
in a world that's very equitable now in
2022 where
males and females sort of share a lot of
the same duties and there's
more women in college these days and
more women attorneys than male attorneys
why is it when you
see a motorcycle going down the road
with a couple on it the guy is still the
guy with his hands on the handlebars and
the woman is
pulled in behind him with her hands on
his waist
why
and i was like i yeah i have some
thoughts i'll let you i'll let you
answer yeah your own question no i'm i'm
seeing now this is what happened to me i
was like yeah i never thought of that
but it's true
i've not seen any women riding the bike
with the guy in the back
but in a world where we the guy stays
home and takes care of the kids and the
woman goes to work and you know he's
making dinner and everything all the
responsibilities are shared now
why do we still have this
in this one place also it's like see a
lot of women driving with a guy in the
passenger seat now you know you didn't
see that so much when i was growing up
so i'll be curious your take
on that and then i'll tell you what i
said well first on the uh why the man is
always driving when the woman's in the
car i never understood that growing up
it was like a running joke in my family
because my my i knew my mom knew how to
drive she'd somehow drive us to get ice
cream or go play basketball but somehow
if my dad was in the car it was as if my
mom had no ability to drive whatsoever
sometimes we'd be fighting in the back
and my dad would turn to my mom you want
to drive and i'll deal with them and my
mom would freak out as if she has no
idea where any of the shift and the
wheel and the whole thing um on the
first part was the wire men on the front
of the bicycle and the on the bike and
the and the women on the back i think
it's actually because a lot of
traditional gender role stuff does make
sense and people actually it's not even
that they crave it they they sort of
automate towards it either way and it's
not to say there aren't things that are
good that can be a little bit different
than that sort of ideal situation but
uh i think it's just how it is it would
be odd it would be odd but not
impossible if you saw the chick
you know holden holding the uh the
motorcycle and the guy holding her it
just it doesn't fully compute it's not
impossible it just kind of is men are
men right usually more protectors you
know
hunter
the whole thing
but we have like admirals who are
transgender now and stuff you know i
mean like we're all
i get it that's the way it was but those
rules don't apply to 2022 everything has
been flipped over and turned over and
changed i'll i'll tell you the real
answer
please the real answer
is
the couples that are
would be considered a progressive couple
the couple i spoke of the couple where
maybe the guy stays home and does the
dishes and the woman goes to work and
all that
they would never own a motorcycle yeah
they're too sc they're scared the
motorcycles wait these are double masker
couples we're talking about this is wipe
everything down with purell this is put
a helmet on the kid when he goes outside
that's who they are a motorcycle is far
too dangerous for that couple they would
never own a motorcycle
the couples that do own the motorcycles
who are willing to deal with the danger
of a motorcycle are old school couples
so they have and i bet their life
reflects that i bet in that couple the
guy goes to work and the woman stays
home and raises the kids and what have
you so you only see traditional folks on
the motorcycles because they would never
have a motorcycle in a progressive
relationship
so basically they've they've selected
they've self-selected themselves in is
it is it kind of fun for you in a way
now like when you're doing stand-up or
you're doing your show or you're writing
a book that it's like you're mostly a
libertarian and at least in my eyes i
don't know if you officially call
yourself anything but like that that
this sort of like basically rough sanity
is now starting to be funny like that's
actually starting to work while the woke
stuff and all the crappy netflix
specials by you know these not really
comedian comedians they're all nobody's
watching any of them
yeah it's now we've come to the point
where you can kind of make fun of of
people who are
insane
and uh
somehow
there's a little light at the end of the
tunnel you know we're in l.a we're
talking about
bringing masks back and there are people
now who go i'm not going along with this
this is nuts they didn't say anything a
year and a half ago but they're starting
to wake up a little bit
and so you can kind of do that on stage
now too whereas
two years ago you i mean i did anyway
but people
people are you know freaked out about
everything you can you can slowly start
to make fun of you know the insane
massed up
transgenderized world that we've created
um uh suddenly as you were saying that
i'm reminded of a clip you you had gavin
newsom on your show what like a decade
ago or something
yeah a little less but yeah
you had gavin newsom outside so maybe
eight years ago something like that and
uh you you smacked him around pretty
good which i have to tell you as a guy
that fled the state because of that guy
made me feel pretty good
do you hold that one does that have a
special place in your heart
yeah it is um if people can see it on
youtube if they if they like i imagine i
think it's out there
um he came in here i didn't really have
anything against him per se at the time
um he agreed to come in and sit down and
did kind of a long form interview with
him
there's a couple of
caveats a
he came in he would never
come in to a place like this now or
anything near anything like that number
one number two
you know it wasn't a quick hit on
news 11 it was as long as as we had
and so he couldn't escape you know he
couldn't was there's no segment you know
that ended in three minutes and he was
going to take off with his security
detail he was just trapped in the studio
with me
and i wasn't planning on going after him
i'm not i don't really
work that way my
idea when i interview people is i want
to interview people but i will ask him
questions and
he started off so i don't think people
really know how
intellectually
troubled he is or bankrupt or or
something i don't i don't really know
whether to call him a liar or an
imbecile or just a sellout or whatever
it is but
i don't understand frankly i just
believe he has no human soul
that's just me there's something there's
something wrong with him and when i what
i mean is is like
kamala harris there's something wrong
with her and that when lester holt is
asking if you've been to the border she
doesn't know what he's saying like that
there's a synapse problem there's
something wrong now look
you can just lie and just go yeah i
haven't been to the border yet but i'm
closely monitoring the border and i'm
planning on going later this week just
just lie but to go i don't know what
you're asking means something's wrong
with you and something's wrong with a
lot of the biden has something wrong
with him obviously kamala harris
newsom has something wrong with him and
so there's a couple of things one is is
i said to him
look uh
traffic is is horrible in this town can
we work on traffic a little bit
and he said uh yeah
first off it's all kind of news to him
he's like well what do you want you know
what do you want me to do it's this
weird thing you know where they don't
no you you don't sit in traffic like
you're kind of unaware and i said so i
said a few things i said
in idaho
there's signs by the side of the highway
that says if it steers it clears and in
la
i see people in the third lane on the
405 freeway
both people out of their car because
they had a little bumper bender the cars
are fine no airbags deployed and they're
like standing in the third lane
exchanging information and my thing is
like pull over pull
pull off to the shoulder it's like we
got into a car accident i know the car's
fine just pull it over and get your
information a people get killed that way
it happens
often and b you you've stopped the whole
freeway because you guys are having a
conversation
in the middle of the freeway and your
cars run
i said put it up on the freeway sign
just if it steers it clears they they
have them in all the different states
and so the first thing he went was he
went
uh
really
you know
uh get out of here you know kind of
thing and i said no that's they have it
he's like i never
never heard of that so he never heard of
that and then he rebutted it with this
and this is what
makes gav this is why something is wrong
with gavin newsom he said you know i'd
say i saw something he started chuckling
he goes i saw something i liked saw a
sign i liked
it said
you're not in traffic
you are traffic
and i kind of like that and i'm like
i don't know what that means but it
certainly doesn't feel like a way to
alleviate the problem
of traffic
so it's an insane statement to say
you're not you know it's like i'm
i'm an oncologist you don't have cancer
you are cancer all right my work is done
like i i don't know what he's talking
about then he said
i heard him in another interview
when he went on to a friendly show
but the the person the woman who was
interviewing him at least was had enough
dignity to say
hey people are fleeing california you
know this this was a recent interview
what uh what are we gonna do about that
i mean you have thoughts about people
just leaving california
and he said uh you know uh
my answer to that is
where else you're gonna go
and the host can think of at least one
place
yeah the host said uh i don't know
florida texas nashville like
just anywhere and then he said yeah i
know i look no i didn't say that jerry
brown used to say that
so he quoted a guy
and then disavowed himself of whatever
the quote was jerry brown
jerry brown in 1974 would say where else
you're gonna go and so gavin newsom
decided to repeat that and when the
person said yeah that but that doesn't
make sense he went yeah i know jerry
brown said that that
which means you're you may it means
it means you're insane it means you have
a problem it means you're not thinking
correctly and then he started up
with me i
i said the homeless this is nine years
ago i said the homeless problem
is
crazy people and junkies and both that's
who's homeless and then he said let me
explain to you the real face of
homelessness he prefaced it by saying
that was his main issue and that's what
he cared about the most and then he
explained to me
the real face of homelessness
the real picture of homelessness was a
mother three
whose husband left and who had a minimum
wage job and was forced out into the
streets
and i said that's not that's not who's
living on the streets so very announced
his number one issue
was homelessness he was he said he was
passionate about it then went on to
explain a scenario that doesn't exist
and now
that was nine years ago and homelessness
is
tenfold worse so that's who
gavin newsom is and i i don't know i
really i'm not i'm always curious why
the people around him go don't don't say
that or like why are you
that's not the problem of homelessness
is not mothers of three
who are making minimum wage
what do you make of the people that are
bamboozled by him and by the way the
only reason i'm even asking you about
him besides the fact that for some
reason you're still there and i've fled
is that i'm pretty sure that
as you know because i'm off the grid at
the moment i could come back and he
could be vice president because i think
this whole thing is completely out of
control they're keeping biden alive on
god knows what and you know he visited
the white house when uh
you know when joe went off to israel
vice president interesting
you know you figure out something to get
nancy out of the way something like that
you get kamala
and um gavin newsom in the same room and
you're going to have a nothing circle
talk of in complete and utter insanity
we're going to have two people who make
no sense and who don't track at all
um what i make of it is
la california especially and then
people in general
they're very
sort of in hollywood you go now why
you know why hollywood they loved obama
they they they love new some you know
like like why
they're aesthetically oriented
and i don't mean it's all about like
matinee idol good lucks they just kind
of go
they if they said look i'm gonna show
you a picture i'm going to take everyone
hollywood and show you a picture i'll
show you a picture of gavin newsom i'm
going to show you a picture of donald
trump who do you want as a pilot in your
airplane they'll go oh i want that guy
with the jawline for sure he's a much
better pilot he's got to be in look at
this guy
this guy's this guy's eating a
cheeseburger look at this guy that guy's
my pilot that's it's literally like
they're casting a movie all the time
like you know george clooney looks like
he knows what he's doing you know and
they're so aesthetically oriented and
sort of
paper-thin
and there's such this weird living life
on kind of the veneer surface of life
that they go that guy look at that guy
yeah look at obama that guy and then you
you go well let's talk about policies
and go no no no
let's not get
mired in that look at that guy i'd like
to have a beer with that guy
that's basically what they do with gavin
newsom
they're idiots but that's how that's how
it works that that's literally why why
does hollywood
hollywood
hated
with a with a red hot burning fever they
hated trump
a lot of that was just a and it was was
an aesthetic and a style they just was
driven so nuts by his look and his
mannerisms that they this didn't care
about anything else they just hated him
where would that hatred
weird visceral hatred come from
they're so shallow that they they work
base basically on an aesthetic
they love aoc for that reason right i
was on hannity a month ago and i just
went if if if aoc was a middle-aged
chubby chick
from minnesota would anyone listen to a
word that she had to say and then
everyone turned on me and they're like
how could you say that it's like what do
you mean how can i say it because it's
patently true
if she was amy klobuchar everyone would
think she'd be as popular as amy
klobuchar
that's right that's exactly right
what do we do
to get out of this mess that we seem to
be stuck in
well
you know
the thing
about this mess
is and i i bring it up all the time
certainly when i'm talking to dr drew
who still lives in california
it's always any time i talk to anyone
with a couple of brain cells rubbed
together it's like they always go well
we got a bottom out and we haven't quite
bottomed out yet but we'll bottom out
then when we bottom out then we'll we'll
change
and i go
can't we see ourselves bottoming out
like why do we always have to completely
bottom out yeah you know what i mean
like like it's basically like saying
you know i got a 15 year old daughter
and i had to remove all the nail polish
remover from her room because she was
huffing it
and you go with you want to get her some
help i got to wait till she od's like
i'll wait till she flatlines
and here you go yeah how about getting
her some counseling now she's she's
drinking
nail polish remover like yeah but she
hasn't flat she hasn't gone into cardiac
arrest
it's like yeah oh
okay so
california is bottoming out but we've
not
utterly bottomed out and so we have to
wait until we physically make contact
with the floor of the basement and then
we'll go you know i think we got to get
some new new thoughts in here is is the
bizarre part of that too that there is
no such thing as the floor there like no
one would ever agree oh now it can't get
worse than this because and i was only
there for eight years but it just got
worse and worse it was not terrible when
i got there then obviously covet
escalated it but it's like everyone
you're right every everybody that i
would see in l.a oh well it's got to get
worse before it gets better that's what
they always say it's got to get worse
before it gets better to wake up people
i don't think people will ever agree on
how worse it has to get
no you're right it's basically
you have an nfl coach he's three and 13
every year
and then you go shouldn't we get a new
coach and i go where do we go one in 15.
the problem is you're not drafting
anybody to california to save the place
if you had a draft pick involved maybe
this thing makes sense but there are no
drafts as far as i know have you lost
are all your friends leaving
a lot of them well i would say probably
more people
who are more conservative are leaving
and
the less conservative ones are kind of
writing it out and also
you know there's a version of living in
california where you just make a ton of
money and kind of hang out in malibu
where you can sort of go
whatever wherever that bridge is they
built and boil heights i'm not going
over that bridge i i'm going on the
malibu pier
so there's definitely a lot of that
you're having breakfast at nobu aren't
you
you elitist yes
that's right we'll go the soho house
afterward for lunch
adam what's wrong with joe biden
i've been trying to figure it out i
think something's wrong with the guy you
kind of alluded to it what's wrong with
man
well i
i would say there's you know if you're
gonna try to figure out what's wrong
with joe biden you have to kind of
break it off into into stages you know
kind of early middle and present day joe
biden
the
the beginning part of joe biden
was and i don't think people really took
a big enough accounting of this but like
when he was like
i was at the head of my law school class
i was the only student with a dual
degree and a dual major and two whatever
and i did 15 000 on the sats all right
buddy you want to do a push-up contest
and then later on it was like yeah he
was at the bottom of his class he never
got a degree and he didn't take the sats
someone should have pumped the brakes
right there and went that's a sociopath
there's something wrong yeah now you
look
i was i don't like to talk about myself
dave but no no no no no
please i i'll grant you this one i was
just this one moment and then we can go
back your listeners can enjoy you
i was
first team
all
central valley at north hollywood high
in football
and every once in a while
somebody's talking and you know i'm
doing an interview on some sports show
or something adam was an all-city
football player and i go no not all city
i wasn't all city that's that's higher
it was all valley all central valley so
get it straight
now why well the answer is i wasn't all
city and i'm just not comfortable with
being labeled all city when i was all
valley a lower degree
so
there's something wrong with his
character number one that he would just
plagiarize and lie and lie and lie
now he's sort of sociopathic that way
now there's obviously some cognition
issues that are going on now which have
just exacerbate exacerbated what he was
now when people ask him did you ever
talk to your son about his day hey bud i
never talked hey hey
hey dutch hey duke
hey hey bub i i hey mac i didn't talk i
never said what ever and it's like
he has no ability to go
well look every
first off
if your son owned a
frozen yogurt place in pasadena you
would talk to him about his business on
thanksgiving dinner right you'd go son
how's the soft swirl going and he'd go
hey don't winter just talk to pinkberry
in pasadena okay
the monday's pretty solid too late
the point is is i've never talked to my
son ever about any of his it's like
well that makes you a horrible dad
doesn't it right
right um but
he has this
thing where now he's angered if anyone
challenges him
he does not have there's no gray area
you know when somebody talks about uh
you go back just go back and look at all
the clips like during the debates with
trump it's like hey your business
dealings with china i my business i
never did i don't have anyone it's him
it's trump did he did it's like
your son's all over business dealings
with china like
you know you can say
hey it's a nuanced subject when you
become a politician you meet a lot of
people you don't know who you're taking
a photo op with all the time i'm not you
know i can't keep tr i don't look at my
calendar down to the last second so yeah
i probably met a few guys from a few
places and i get what it what it looks
like but i never profited off it or
whatever he's just like 100 never
happened shut it down no
he is really kind of sociopathic and i
don't think people really fully
understand it
he you know when it i mean his tells are
whenever he says true story true story
or whatever he's always lying wherever
he says the word truth there's a lie
there but also
telling those stories like where he's
saying you know when i you know 1953 i'd
be walking with my dad through the
streets of scranton and we'd see two
fellas hugging and my dad would look at
me and go that's what love is son and i
literally you know what you're right
that never happened that never happened
and kamala harris was marching with
harriet tubman and wanted freedom when
she was two it's like hey
why doesn't this
bother people more this kind of weird
and then what people do is they go well
look at trump
yeah trump said there were a million
people at the inauguration and there
were seven hundred thousand people in
the inauguration i get it he's a poster
he's an exaggerator
this he's not inserting himself into
like zelic into a pieces of history that
like never happened or just lying about
i've two degrees like you don't have one
degree i was at the head of my law
school you you're at the bottom you're
in the bottom 10 like that's insane
and it's and it's a tell
and most people don't take it as a tell
but they should
you think he's going to make it all the
way i mean you kind of hit on the mental
stuff something ain't right
i look
i don't know maybe you and i were early
money on this but
a year and a year ago
a year and a half ago they're like you
think he's running for i said he's not
he's no he's not running for a second
term they were like why not you don't
think he wants to be pres like he's not
he's not going to be here he's not going
to be able to physically
i was on bill maher's show and he's like
is he going to run and you know of
course he's going to run and i said
he's going to run for i said he can't he
can barely walk
forget about running for president no i
and i said early i don't know if he's
making it out of the first
term
yeah
on inauguration day i think i said i'll
retire i'll end my show if he makes it
through the whole first term i think i'm
looking pretty good at the moment
but let me uh you mentioned if they want
to prop him up and just sort of if they
want to do what they want to do if the
the news outlets and the mainstream
media and everyone wants to just kind of
circle the wagons and
prop him up i suppose they could ride it
out
if they really want to go down that
route that that hole
sorry go ahead
no no well you mentioned mar and i i
talk about mar a lot on this show so
whatever parties you're still invited to
i'm going to get you disinvited to all
of them right now because i talk about
marlot like sort of as the he's the
prototypical sort of i'm not a crazy
woke lefty i'm good on free speech i i'm
against crt i'm against the gender stuff
i finally came out against lockdowns you
know i'm sane on most of this stuff the
conservatives always applaud him then he
calls them racist they get upset for a
minute then he says something's sane
they applaud again uh what do you think
is going on there and do you think
there's a way to like get a guy like him
to to get over the hump and realize that
the people that he's supporting are are
importing all of the stuff that he hates
he's
a guy who's
intellectually honest who can be a
little naive sometimes
in that
i remember he had adam schiff on his
show
maybe a year ago
he did the one-on-one interview with him
and he said
and this is kind of him being
intellectually honest and naive at the
same time he's like look adam
you come on my show you go on cnn you go
on anderson cooper you know what i mean
what you really need to do is go on
hannity or go on tucker and straighten
those people out you know i mean you're
preaching to the choir on joy reid show
go on hannity i wish that guy would put
you on his show so you could go over
there
adam schiff because he's a coward sort
of mumbled under his breath i've been
invited a few times and then
bill maher who's naive was like
well then why not go
because he'd get his ass handed to him
because he's a liar
and they would have facts and he would
be destroyed yeah okay go talk to ben
shapiro go talk to dennis pray go go
talk to those guys they never talk to
those guys because they get destroyed
or gavin newsom come on back for round
two come on back [ __ ] let's have it out
bring a notepad i won't write anything
down how about it come on back
he won't come back because he'll be
destroyed
so mars a little naive like hey go on
hannity and go coach him up
and
so that's kind of the new the naive part
the other part of him that's sort of
honest and hopeful is
yeah you got a message spread why
wouldn't you why do you keep going to
the people that already converted go go
outside i i said the same thing about
fouchy the whole time
you oh these these uh these unwashed
walmart shop and gun toting hannity
watching people they don't they're not
getting the vaccine they're not wearing
they're not getting the message we got
to get to those people well don't do it
on joy read show fouchy go on hannity
and straighten everyone out
but you won't because you're coward and
you know there'd be pushback and they'd
ask questions and you couldn't answer
those questions so you won't but it's
insane for someone like fauci who's
trying to spread the message to
the right who won't go on shows of the
right
that's an interesting conceit and also
that this this [ __ ] where people
like
well he wouldn't be treated fairly what
do you mean treated fairly gavin newsom
can come into my studio and say whatever
the [ __ ] avenues wants i'm allowed to
push back he then is allowed to correct
me we didn't treat it fairly
i i love that no-show he knows he's not
going to be treated for it no he's not
he's he's going to be treated like a
guest and there's going to be a debate
now go ahead and bring all your facts
and beat up tucker with your information
it's funny because i get that too
they'll say okay well you wouldn't treat
them fairly and it's like you know for
all these people that i make fun of all
the time i've never treated a guest
poorly once i have never treated any
guest any differently than any other
guest there are people who maybe i agree
with more but i treat these people all
the same and i would treat any of these
people with with respect but i would ask
hopefully the right questions along the
way but you're right that their their
stuff is so thin that they know you can
kind of just poke right through it so
they'd rather call us nazis adam
yeah so
mar who i know well
and who's a good guy
is his basic conceit and i think it's
the same with many democrats and many
people
in california for sure which is
look
there's too much regulation there's too
much red tape housing housing is too
expensive taxes are too high and
wildfires and water shortages and the
schools suck
fine
but would you really want a racist
running the state
like that's all that's all at the end
you really think that's that's like he
really believes it i think you're
probably right
that's basically how it comes that's
just what it comes down to and then
the people that have a bunch of money
and send their kids to private school go
yeah you know what i don't care that
there's traffic and i don't care that
the
grid is is broken and i don't care that
we're running out of water i just would
not want some homophobic bigot
running the state or or as the president
or whatever and they go so it's still
better and
you know maybe the answer is
yeah if that were true
i mean if larry elder was the actual
black face of white supremacy or
something or dennis prager was a white
supremacist then i would tend to agree
i'd still be a little more pragmatic and
probably go well i'm white so what i got
to worry about but
yeah i would go yeah i know people that
are gay or black or something yeah i
would not want to vote for the hitlerian
you know stalin-esque dictator whatever
but they're not intellectually honest
enough to go what do you mean he's a
racist
like where where's that coming from oh
the la times said he's right
oh okay but don't they call everyone a
race
as you said and i quote you all the time
how could it be that everyone who
disagrees with our side when you're on
the left is a racist how's that
mathematically possible that's our
argument
hey i want to talk about water stop
working for me
i'm gonna build a desalination plant in
redondo beach oh because you're racist
like could is everything race i mean if
you just disagree with everything
the race i i want uh i like fracking and
cheap oil okay
i get it homophobe i get it
yeah transphobe
corolla i'm going to save my most
important question for our locals
community for the subscribers because
i'm a greedy capitalist aka racist we're
going to do that in just a second is
there anything else you want the good
people to know about about the book
which we're going to link to down below
because we're a professional program
uh it's a very funny book
go to amazon read the reviews if you
like what you read go get it and you
will laugh and
you know in a world where there's a lot
of problems and people are pretty
serious
having a laugh is probably going to be
good
for your soul
adam carolla good luck in california my
friend
thank you if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about comedy instead of the non-stop
yelling you get everywhere else check
out our comedy playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell